i wanted to actually start uh with a
challenge a little puzzle people were
probably familiar with the tetrahedron
and here's a square based pyramid so the
triangular faces are both the same on
these shapes the challenge for you and
we perhaps solve it at the end of the
video is if i put these two shapes
together tell me how many faces there
are on the shape that i would make by
fusing two of the triangular faces
together
okay okay there's your challenge um you
might think
it doesn't sound terribly difficult for
us number five um so but we'll look at
that at the end what i wanted to talk
about in this video was an interesting
thing i discovered working with a
sculptor that lives nearby my house here
is very famous actually conrad shaw
cross and he loves using mathematical
shapes in the sculptures that he makes
and one of the early challenges he faced
he realized that using a bit of
mathematics
actually cut down the amount of work
that he had to do as a sculptor so he's
been really obsessed with this shape the
tetrahedron he sort of thought this was
like one of the great building blocks of
nature and indeed he's right the ancient
greeks of course
thought the platonic solids were
the kind of atoms or that made up the
universe so at that time we thought
earth wind fire and water were the atoms
of the universe and each of those would
have a shape earth that was the shape of
the cube water the icosahedron made out
of 20 equilateral triangles air was the
octahedron made out of eight equilateral
triangles and fire was this shape here
the tetrahedron the kind of spikiest of
the shapes of course we've got one
platonic solid left over which is the
dodecahedron and plato left that to be
the shape of the universe which kind of
be interesting um but conrad shawcross
was was interested as a sculptor and
yeah well what about taking this atomic
shape the tetrahedron and and seeing
what he can build
out of it so one of his very first
projects he built 2 000 tetrahedrons and
set himself the task of trying to see
what he could build out of these
tetrahedrons and actually he had a
deadline and suddenly the deadline looms
and he's got to try and find how to put
these 2000 tetrahedron together but then
he talked to a mathematician who said
well you realize you don't actually have
2 000 objects you've got to find how to
put them together in fact you have a
much smaller number of building blocks
because if you put two tetrahedron
together for example there's really only
one shape you can make out of that there
isn't another way i can put these
tetrahedron together
and get a different sort of shape so
already actually you've halved the
problem and and this is the power of
symmetry you know that's my area of
expertise symmetry
symmetry often is a clever way of
cutting down
a problem which at first sight seems
like there are you know 2 000 different
things you've got to put together but
then he realized no actually
you can halve that there are only a
thousand objects that you need to
consider i just got to put these
together um but the mathematician said
no in fact you can cut it down even more
because
if i have three tetrahedron
there's only one way i can put three
tetrahedron together so here are my
little paper tetris i made earlier for
you here's our two put together but
actually there's only one way i can
attach a third object and what i make is
this kind of weird
shape almost little like a boat isn't it
so you might say okay well that's one
way to put the tetrahedron together but
maybe i can fuse this on a different
edge and look i've got something
different but of course the point is
that symmetry means that i can turn this
and i've always got that little boat
structure so it doesn't matter how many
different ways i try the symmetry means
i always get the same object so
conrad used this
as a shortcut in a way the symmetry of
how you put these together to say i
don't need to consider 2000 i only need
to consider a third of that and use this
as my basic building block and that's
what he used to make some of his first
interesting structures out of this
tetrahedron but if you go up to four
then it then you do and you lose it four
you can start yeah then you start to um
have uh different directions that you're
coming out and so this is really the
basic building block for his sculptures
is this particular one here but then
there are new decisions you've got to
make and what he found was there were
interesting tendrils quite unexpected
shapes that emerge out of this if you
look at conrad's work you see just
amazing kind of
weird directions that he's been taken on
by this particular object and recently
he's discovered a kind of new sort of
shape which i actually
had not been aware of because one of the
interesting thing is with platonic
solids which of them can you pack and
fill space with a cube clearly you can
stack cubes and and fill the whole of
space but do any of the other objects
actually fill space you can take a
slightly non-symmetrical tetrahedra and
squash it a bit um and fill space with
that but with the actual symmetrical
tetrahedron if you try and fill space it
doesn't work and there's always kind of
a little bit left over
and conrad's made this very interesting
shape that looks like it's trying to be
a an icosahedron it's sort of building
up lots of triangles but they don't
quite fit together and there's kind of
an interesting gap i think that's very
interesting an artist using these shapes
to sort of discover very asymmetrical
shape made out of these tetrahedrons it
looks like it's trying to be something
symmetrical but doesn't quite work it's
kind of interesting the sweet spot
between something that is trying to be
perfect but it isn't quite
does that tetrahedral boat have a name
it really should do doesn't it i mean
but now you've challenged me with that i
i don't know what that would be called
um perhaps people in the comments down
below either we can christen it uh give
it a name or maybe somebody does know a
name for that perhaps it could be called
the shaw cross shape or something
it is a little bit bow to you so so i
think it's interesting how you can use
symmetry very often to to cut down the
hard work you've got to do and very
often in when i'm looking at a
particular mathematical problem
sometimes you're looking at an equation
um and it can be solved in many
different ways uh but spotting that
actually all of the solutions are kind
of symmetrical versions of each other is
often a way of cutting down the work you
just have to find one solution and then
use the symmetry to find all of the
others so that's a very
uh common trick in mathematics and in
science first intriguing is the first
time i've seen it used by a sculptor as
a you know oh yeah use the symmetry and
cut down the work
what work was he cutting down um
professor was it was it was he having to
cast less pieces or something like that
well he'd actually made all of these 2
000
cubes out of wood but what he'd cut down
was just what he needed to put together
was these three and then they were the
building blocks from which everything
else you know there was nothing new that
would emerge if he hadn't have done that
at first i think there may be many more
possibilities but the symmetry showed no
all of these are actually examples of
the same thing so maybe we should come
back to our little challenge because
that was about putting shapes together
and understanding uh
what shape emerges by putting two
together so uh a first sight you may say
this is pretty obvious um this shape has
five
faces this one has four faces when i put
these together i lose two faces so five
plus four is nine
uh so i should get seven faces
what's the big uh problem but something
rather
curious happens because when i put these
together i lose two more faces because
look at this these two line up and so
these two actually become one face so
this object actually has five faces one
two
three
four
five faces so there's a little bit of a
surprise that comes out of that i hope
you perhaps experience that oh that's
unexpected um and what's curious about
this is this was
set in one of the sat exams uh in
america um just to see how good you are
at conceptual visualization and they
didn't realize that um this kind of
rather curious answer so
the the people who said seven
got the score and those who said five um
were given no marks at all but actually
it turns out rather curiously that when
you put these together um this shape
actually only has five faces in this
shape you've got um two
faces on this side and two that faces on
this side that fuse so so actually this
which you might have first thought
counted as uh two different faces you've
got one two
um three the square on the bottom and
the last triangle there five
totally got me yeah i know yeah uh
i would have gotten back in the sats
though
exactly that was what was so crazy
see the links in the description for
more videos with marcus de sortoi plus
links to his books and theater
productions other things he's up to so
for example you might want to know well
is this particular statement provable
from the axioms